what's going on guys this is rob and as
promised we're gonna do a breakdown on
the trailer the new trailer for
spider-man no way home right so the
easter eggs everything you missed all
that kind of good stuff now we have to
address the elephant in the room the big
talking point that everybody is
addressing the brazilian trailer now for
those of you guys who don't know what's
going on with that there was a brazilian
trailer that was released and in the
trailer that we saw here in the states
there's that point where like the lizard
and all those guys go charging towards
spider-man and it's like a great big
huge thing but in the brazilian trailer
that scene lasts about two or three
seconds longer and the lizard gets
punched away by somebody that we don't
see now people have basically been
analyzing it and breaking it down and
due to the fact that it seems to have
kind of been edited poorly and in a rush
you can kind of see an arm there and so
the big thing is going on is people are
saying that's either toby maguire or
andrew garfield but basically their
presence in the trailer was removed
presumably by marvel in order for the
actual trailer to be released without
any major spoilers involving their
characters i say by marvel because if
you guys recall the rumors and the
discussions that were going on recently
apparently sony and marvel were butting
heads over whether or not toby mcguire
and andrew garfield should appear in the
trailer given what we saw in the trailer
that came out last night looks like
marvel won out and based on the footage
from the brazilian trailer it also looks
like marvel went out but that small
little edit seems to indicate that
either that or the lizard was hit by
just a ridiculously strong gust of wind
and like his head just kind of got blown
back so it could only be one of those
two things
but getting into the meat and potatoes
of this trailer i just want to reiterate
the same thing that i said last night
electro looks amazing god he looks so
good i always thought he looked kind of
goofy and terrible in like the other
spider-man movies but in this one he
looks phenomenal i absolutely love the
way his character looks man it's how
electro should have looked the entire
time i think it's just
i'm not even gonna lie
i'm kind of more excited to see him that
i am anybody else right i love jamie
foxx i'm a ridiculously huge jamie foxx
fan right so having the chance to like
actually see him
as electro
the way that maxwell dillon is supposed
to look
it's just
it's amazing i always felt like he
should have played adam beshear in the
marvel cinematic universe either him or
john david washington but that's neither
here nor there let's get into our
coverage here so first things first one
of the big talking points here is what
people noticed in the initial trailer
when it came out that the tentacles of
dr octopus had a kind of red coloring to
it and the coloring looked like stark
tech right like the iron man suit the
iron spider suit so the on running
theory here was that dr octopus in his
fight with peter parker with tom holland
had basically absorbed the iron spider
suit off of him and assimilated that
nano technology into his own tentacles
and that's why they look the way they do
this trailer gives us a little more
insight here and i don't think that's
fully what's happening i think that's
kind of what happened but not to that
same degree obviously there is
discoloration there's a change in color
and in fact in that scene in the trailer
in one of the first three opening shots
and then they show it again later on
when the camera is panning around dr
octopus and you see his tentacle arms
they're actually changing and so if you
fast forward or you look at that point
where dr octopus has spiderman captured
and he says you're not peter parker his
tentacles have the same coloring but
peter parker is still wearing the iron
spider suit so what it looks like is in
their initial conflict their initial
skirmish maybe some of the suit was
siphoned off of peter parker and
absorbed by dr octopus either that or he
found some way to get his hands on stark
tech before the two of them fought
something else that i noticed and i'm
sure all you guys noticed is that dr
octopus once he sees the face of tom
holland says like you're not spider-man
obviously that's him saying you're not
tobey maguire which is fine that's
obvious that's on the nose what i think
is less obvious and what i think is more
important here is the fact that it looks
like he was yanked into the marvel
cinematic universe and doesn't know he
doesn't realize that he's in a wholly
different universe now now it could be
one of those things where he is yanked
into this new universe and then he sees
spider-man and believes that spider-man
is yanked into that universe with him so
like he knows what's going on and as
soon as he unmasked or as soon as tom
holland unmasks himself he realizes it's
not toby mcguire i'm inclined to believe
it's the former that he was yanked into
the marvel cinematic universe and
doesn't know the big problem with that
is it has to have been done before the
fight on the bridge the only way that
scenario could make sense that he was
yanked into the mcu mid-fight with toby
mcguire is that the fight between him
and toby maguire would have to basically
be identical to the fight he was
engaging in or that he would be engaging
in with tom hall and spider-man right so
it's like walking through a barrier and
nothing changes everything's the exact
same right the moves the way spider-man
swinging all that kind of stuff it'd
have to be perfectly identical that's
just ridiculous there's no conceivable
way that could be the case so it looks
to me like he was yanked into the marvel
cinematic universe before the fight
between himself and tom holland he
didn't know he was in the marvel
cinematic universe and for whatever
reason a fight breaks out between the
two of them now one of the more obvious
things that i think has a less obvious
implication here is when doctor strange
tells peter parker when you botched the
spell we started getting all these
visitors from across the multiverse now
i still stick by the idea that the
events of loki are what caused this
because if you look at the loki tv show
right if you look at that when a mortise
basically said we crossed the threshold
this was verified as having been a
reference to when wanda became the
scarlet witch the reason why i bring
that up is because this wouldn't be the
first time that we see an event from
loki coincide with another event in the
mcu remember one of the things that was
established in loki is that space and
time are synonymous you can't have one
without the other and so the death of a
mortise at the hands of sylvie and the
entire multiverse breaking free and
flying into a state of disarray it would
make perfect sense that instead of the
spell being screwed up by peter parker
it just happened to look that way
because the spell dr strange cast
happened right at the same time when
immortus was killed and the multiverse
broke free the reason why i side with
that is because dr strange is the
sorcerer supreme right i mean this guy's
dedication and knowledge of magic is
unparalleled and unrivaled by anybody
with the exception of wanda and even
that's a little bit dubious agatha said
she's destined to become more powerful
than the sorcerer supreme we don't know
what she actually is and so if doctor
strange is really just that capable and
that powerful and understands the
significance of creating such a complex
spell i have a hard time believing that
spell would be screwed up by a teenage
kid who couldn't shut the hell up i just
don't see that being the case
i just don't see that being the case
right it just it seems a little goofy to
me so i think it's more practical and
more reasonable that the events of loki
are actually what sent the spell awry
now building on top of that right when
dr strange tells peter parker that after
this spell's been botched we got
visitors from every universe
i think this is a very important thing
because while this does tell us how it
is that we get electro and sandman and
doctor octopus and green goblin all
those guys i think what it also means is
there are characters who exist in the
marvel cinematic universe that we
haven't seen yet right that we're not
going to see in this movie or if we do
post credit scenes little cameos
different things along those lines and
more recent news and this is a very
important thing in more recent news one
of the things that's come out is that
it's been verified that wolverine and
professor x will show up in doctor
strange too whether or not they're going
to be in an alternate universe we don't
know but it's entirely possible that
while heroes like that probably wouldn't
be captured by doctor strange and like
forced back into their universe although
it's entirely possible that there are
other villains who exist out there that
we simply haven't seen yet that could
have a future in the marvel cinematic
universe because they're just some of
the people doctor strange has been
capturing if it really is people from
every universe that's an astronomical
number of villains and it just happens
to be that these are the villains that
we're focusing on in the spider-man film
i mean i don't mean to go off on like a
little bit of a tangent here but this
could explain the arrival of galactus
right that's what happened in the events
of age of ultron in marvel comics that
you have galactus in the main marvel
universe then you have galactus in the
ultimate universe who's basically just a
series of robots that's really all it is
right nanobots but when wolverine
screwed up time in the age of ultron
storyline like he broke time galactus
was transported to the ultimate universe
where he basically met his robot
counterpart and the two of them actually
merged it was really really cool but
there's precedent to be set for
characters being yanked over so do i
think this is going to be like
spider-man no way home officially
introducing galactus into the mcu i
don't think so galactus is hugely
significant and way more significant
than to be introduced in the mcu and
some kind of a cameo or a post-credits
scene honestly i mean it'd be cool to
see but i'd be kind of pissed off if you
that was the sort of treatment that he
got right it'd be sort of disappointing
to see that happen now this also begs
the question of the scene where doctor
strange tells them that the villains are
supposed to die in their universes
fighting spider-man right it's their
fate and he says like i'm sorry kid
peter says i'm sorry too and he seems to
yank the box away from doctor strange
there's a couple ways to interpret this
right the first is that if you look at
the scene where doctor strange is saying
like they're coming through right the
portal is opening then that whole
location looks exactly like the location
where the great big huge battle seems to
take place or that huge fight seems to
take place and because of the fact that
dr strange says that when it's at night
and the fight takes place at night it
stands to reason that great big huge
fight that we see between like electro
and sandman and lizard that it all
happens
as that portal opens right like
literally the portal opens they show up
a big fight breaks out and that's it
there's a couple issues with this though
one we don't see green goblin in that
fight and we don't see doctor strange in
that fight and if doctor strange was
present when the portal was opened and
all those villains are there it would
make sense that he would be a part of
that fight and so what this seems to
indicate is that fight actually takes
place later on in the movie more so than
that the scene where spider-man takes
the box away from doctor strange that
seems to happen near the end that
basically it looks like a day's been
saved kind of thing and that doctor
strange is getting ready to take all
those villains put them back into their
universes and basically doom them to
their own deaths and peter parker thinks
it's unfair right they can be fixed or
redeemed or whatever motivation makes
sense to him but he believes they can be
safe so he snatches the box a fight
ensues which culminates in doctor
strange pushing peter parker out of his
own body and then basically telling him
this is just the way it has to be right
or something along those lines we don't
really know maybe peter parker frees the
villains before doctor strange gets his
hands on the box and basically now those
villains officially exist in the mcu
jamie foxx's electro willem dafoe's
green goblin uh alfred molina's doctor
octopus all that kind of stuff they
officially exist there and now they're
part of the mcu that's what makes things
kind of hectic though is because there's
a point in the trailer where peter says
this is all my fault i can't save
everybody so maybe that's kind of the
aftermath right he realizes he can't
save all the villains and the villains
have to go back to their universes and
die he could be saying it's all my fault
because he really is the one who botched
the spell that loki has nothing to do
with it honestly that single phrase
taken out of context has no value
whatsoever and we can infer any number
of different things from that it could
be that quite literally andrew garfield
dies and that's what he's referencing
right i can't save everyone there's
andrew garfield right there his head's
all cracked open and just bleeding out
onto the street i can't save everyone mj
and like that's the end of it right i
mean it could be a reference to any
number of things now one of the big
questions people have is the role dr
octopus plays in this movie that he
almost kind of looks like a good guy in
this movie and honestly i think he does
i think he becomes a hero i think that
the story of his character at the end of
spider-man 2 when he basically redeemed
himself right and basically became a
good guy i think that continues on here
that i think he shows up here or maybe
he just kind of ends up in a fight with
spider-man maybe it's them kind of
reworking a little bit of that ending
from spider-man 2 where basically like
that ending never really happens instead
the fight kind of continues on and
instead of him being redeemed at the end
of spider-man 2 he's redeemed here right
and that's basically it but regardless
of the situation i think dr octopus ends
up becoming a good guy more so than that
i think dr octopus is actually told by
doctor strange you're supposed to die in
your fight against toby mcguire and
here's the reason why i say that the
scene where tom holland and mj and all
them are talking to like dr octopus when
they're like what's your name and he's
like otto octavius they start laughing
at him because at the end of the day it
is kind of a silly name
so he deserves to be laughed at the
shirt that peter is wearing in that
scene looks like the exact same shirt
he's wearing in a couple of other scenes
the first one is when doctor strange
says they're supposed to die in their
fight against spider-man it's their fate
the second one is when he tells them
like go scooby doo all that right you
know get the you know go go figure
everything out but more so than that you
also have the scene where doctor octopus
says like you're chasing ghosts so i
think that segment while it does look
like it's something that could be
chopped up that it doesn't really happen
that way in the actual movie that scene
where dr strange says like they're
supposed to die and otto octavia says
you're chasing ghosts i think that is
actually a whole segment i think that's
an actual scene that does take place in
that movie that otto octavius knows he's
supposed to die right it's a great big
huge pow-wow this doctor strange dr
octopus peter parker mj uh ned leads his
character genki like all those guys
they're all together and that's when you
basically learn the truth of what's
supposed to happen you also have that
scene when elektro tells tom holler
tells peter you're not going to take
this from me right it's his second
chance seemingly his ability to live now
how it is that he would know if dr
octopus is essentially a good guy
working alongside peter that's anybody's
guess i don't really know and i'm just
spitballing here on what elektro meant
by that when he said you're not going to
take this from me also as a quick little
thing i mean i know that ned leeds is
not the name of the actor but i still
say it's basically genki from spider-man
i mean it's a different name
but basically genki
go read ultimate spider-man with miles
morales and you'll know for a fact that
that's basically who he is
now a couple other things or a few other
things that i want to address here right
one of the bigger scenes in the movie
and really one of the big talking points
at least as far as the trailer goes is
the scene where mj falls right we talked
about that in our reaction last night
and it looks like the marvel cinematic
universe mike gwen stacy the character
of mj right those you guys don't know
what that means gwen stacy died right in
the comics that night when stacey died
by jerry conway that was a significant
story that taught peter parker he
couldn't be reckless right he has to be
careful with how he handles people that
are basically weaker than him right he
can't just get carried away and just
sort of be you know have be very devil
may care in terms of how he acts but the
important thing is that's actually how
emma stone's character died in the
andrew garfield movie right the andrew
garfield spider-man gwen stacy died
almost exactly the way she died in the
comics right where he basically saved
her at the last possible moment and
ultimately her head hit the ground and
it essentially killed her right like she
basically ended up dying and so what a
lot of people are saying is that because
emma stone or or because gwen stacy died
in andrew garfield's spider-man movie
that's not
tom holland who saves mj that is
actually andrew garfield and i'll be
honest man that would be a great scene
right like imagine this scene for
example right where you've got mj who's
there and you've basically got tom
holland facing off against all these
different guys as best he possibly can
he's being totally overwhelmed and mj
gets knocked off and he goes like he
literally jumps off just like you saw in
the trailer and he's going to rescue her
and then like the green goblin or
somebody flies in and just like
literally just starts attacking him
right so like mj's just falling to her
death and then andrew garfield saves her
life right this would make perfect sense
especially considering the leaks and
things that we've heard the leaks and
the rumors because one of the things
that the leaks are basically saying is
that most of the fight scenes regarding
what you could call a sinister six
basically take place between tom holland
and them and that's basically it but
doctor strange goes to the universes
where these various villains come from
to grab their spider-man essentially
toby mcguire and andrew garfield and
bring them into the mcu and so that
scene where mj's falling to her death
and like a spider-man saves her that's
when they officially arrive on the scene
right like basically andrew garfield
saves her and then like you got tom
holland standing there with doctor
strange and then basically spider-man's
got backup it sounds like something they
would do right imagine it like the the
alternate reality spider-man appearing
and like the same kind of feeling and
tone when captain america got thor's
hammer in avengers in-game you know what
i mean just like damn like you kind of
knew it was coming right instead of
captain america reaching down to grab
the hammer it's mj falling to her death
and like when you see captain america's
hand grabbing the hammer it's andrew
garfield grabbing her hand and then like
when you see like the hammer fly and it
hits thanos in the back of the head
that's basically mj being saved and then
like when it comes back and then like
captain america catches it that's the
reveal of toby maguire and andrew
garfield that kind of a thing right that
sounds like something the mcu would do
god it gives me chills just thinking
about it but it would be cool it'd be an
amazing review and the reason why is
because as cool as the appearances of
toby maguire and andrew garfield would
be
it can only happen under a couple of
different circumstances either they
appear in the movie at the very very
beginning when you see these villains
just kind of disappearing right just
vanishing being snatched into the mcu
because the spell went awry while
they're fighting those spider-man i
think that's the least likely scenario
that you have it at the very very end
when basically they're returned to their
universes and it's just kind of a
digital or a movie equivalent of letting
our voices trail off as they get into
the fight with their spider-man and we
as the viewer know they're going to die
fighting those spider-man and that's it
right like that's when you see them i
also think that's less likely i think
tony mcguire and andrew garfield
appearing in this movie will happen in
like the third act right i don't think
they're going to be there for most of
the movie i don't think there's going to
be any huge amount of time there there i
think they're going to appear when
doctor strange realizes there's no way
for tom holland to win on his own and
he's got to worry about the other
villains who have escaped who are in
their universe from other realities he
can't focus on these sinister six guys
he's got much bigger fish to fry and so
i think he goes and he grabs toby
maguire and andrew garfield they go help
tom holland while doctor strange goes
and does his thing and that's how you
see the characters in the movie
essentially showing up at the final
fight when tom holland needs backup the
most now this also leads to the
appearance of the black suit and this is
something that a lot of people are
talking about if i'm being honest with
you guys i think this is kind of a
reference to the events of superior
spider-man not in the sense that like dr
octopus takes over the body of peter
parker and becomes like a better
spider-man but in the sense that like
that suit is actually designed by dr
octopus that allows peter parker to use
magical energy basically energy given to
him by doctor strange but we can
interpret this a couple different ways
you do see peter parker swinging through
what looks like a great big huge park
there's a lot of electrical lines power
lines and then you see a scene where
electro forms behind him so that may
very well just be a scene where peter
parker is just swinging through either
trying to get to electro or trying to
escape electro or get to like the
location of where he's supposed to find
him and electro is appearing behind
peter peter just doesn't know he's there
and if that is a suit that's built by dr
octopus and dr octopus is a good guy
then this is very sinister six and the
reason why is because during the
original sinister six story peter parker
fought each member of the team in a
location that was the most conducive for
them so he fought electro and a power
plant different things along those lines
and so it would make perfect sense that
if dr octopus is the one helping peter
that ultimately he's building suits
things peter can use that will help him
face off against these various guys who
are out there right and the reason why
is because if you look at the black suit
it's got wires and different things like
that so it looks like it's designed to
basically channel absorb and redirect
electrical energy which is the exact
kind of suit he would need if he was
going to face off against someone like
electro one of the popular theories that
people have is that tom hardy because
he's now in the mcu maybe he stumbles
across peter parker and peter parker
gets the venom symbiote as cool as that
would be that's just too much because
you have to establish why the venom
simian would bond itself to peter parker
you know you have to establish a whole
bunch of different things right like
that in and of itself is like a 15
minute long segment and this movie is
already packed to the gills just from
what we can see in the trailer i'm not
saying tom hardy venom will not appear
i'm not saying that's not the case it's
just for me i have a hard time believing
that would be the case and i think it's
more practical that the black suit peter
is wearing is a suit that was basically
designed for him by dr octopus now the
other question to ask here is that if in
the comics dr octopus is the one who
leads the sinister six but in this movie
he seems to be working with peter to
defeat what is in effect this sinister
six then who's leading the team now and
i think it's the green goblin i think
that it's norman osborne who's basically
leading this sinister six esque team it
explains a few things the first thing it
explains is why it is that you don't see
him in that giant battle with electro
and sandman and the lizard that he's
actually watching it happen he's out
there somewhere now it could also be
that in that scene because of the fact
that it was basically edited that what
you have is tom holland and you've got
andrew garfield facing off against those
guys and then you've got willem dafoe's
green goblin facing off against tobey
maguire because toby mcguire knows how
to handle it so green goblin's there we
just don't see him in that particular
scene but this also begs the question do
we have two green goblins do we
basically have the version that we're
the most familiar with with the helmet
on his face and then the one that we see
where he's basically zooming in from the
sky with some pumpkin bombs by him and
like missiles flying out of him and
that's basically it i think the answer
to that question is yes that i think
what you have there is willem dafoe
green goblin and james franco green
goblin norman and harry osborne father
and son i think that's why they look
different because willem dafoe this
guy's got blonde hair but when you see
that scene where you have that green
goblin that's like racing in it looks
like he has dark hair james franco had
dark hair so i feel like if they keep
any semblance of the characters intact
it could be willem dafoe because if i
recall he had dark hair in the original
spider-man movie so it could very well
be him but at the end of the day i i
have no idea
i'm guessing here that's probably more
fan wish fulfillment than anything else
there's no real evidence to support that
claim but i still think it would be cool
regardless these are some of the things
or really the cooler things that i
noticed in the trailer and we'll do
future videos based on more stuff that
we've seen more observations as people
dig them up as we dig them up and of
course as always we'll make sure we give
credit where credit's due but if you
guys enjoy this video let us know down
in the comment section thank you guys
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace